hey Golden Boy tried a many years ago
didn't know where deflection was in
Oscar part of that I remember Oscar
Donald Trump that's right yeah Donald
Trump was a part of affliction that's
right Josh Barnett sunk that ship Josh
Brener tested positive and that ship
sunk remember yeah yeah and then the UFC
bought it like right afterwards yeah
yeah dad they had some fun fights though
that fucking Tim Sylvia phaidor fight
was wild as shit Andrei Arlovski Lasky
fader look at Donald Shepherd fader he
would Tom attends yeah that's hilarious
yeah back in the day son yeah Donald
Trump and Tim Sylvia that's allure he
was a totally different character back
then to our troubles like a fun guy like
everybody liked him you wanna boxing
fights yeah people liked him he'd get
cheered on now people are so fucking mad
at him same guy they don't see him that
way no one no they don't they don't man
so he has our security around them that
oh yeah you Hoss - yeah you fucked up
became president yeah huge mistake for
anybody you want to enjoy your life
don't be fucking president as you know
you could disappear get facial surgery
or something so of course once you get
that and booklet with all the secrets of
the history just for that the CFR book
just for that what do you think gives
you that book is it the CIA the NSA or
who comes to you with the book some guy
with no face enough no face yeah like
the guy with the battery and the mast
what is the the watchman who was that
guy inkblot what's his name uh Shaq
Rorschach that's right that guy yeah he
comes to you he comes to you with the
thought of yeah he thinks in that book
we tell me I don't know what's in that
book you don't know what's in the book
you think I'm gonna say hearing what
minions are people listening get killed
I can't say I've seen the book I can't
what do you think's in the program what
do you think if you had guess like let's
say president Jorge your first day in
office mr. mas Vidal words like to would
you like to go over first is Elvis still
alive what about Tupac where the fuck
were stupid
well what's going on with these evenings
were they real which is mine number one
the one number one I want to know about
aliens I was hoping this is my hope when
all these people screaming the streets
about the Trump like no I was hoping the
moment he gets in he's gonna ask about
aliens cuz Trump's into conspiracies
like used to go on the how it's Joan
Shaw all time I know he's any
conspiracies if you were gonna be the
president the first thing you'd ask is
fucking aliens what do you got she was
going on here with these green fellows
yeah what's going on with them you live
in Florida there's plenty of aliens down
there now we got oh yeah we got a lot of
aliens different types of aliens